when you guys come to Vegas you guys
already know that you're supposed to eat
at a buffet that's mandatory if you
don't need it have a fan Vegas if you
don't know how to bake a [ __ ] up we're
over here at but the channel bacchanal
mache no boo channel I have no idea how
to pronounce buffet but apparently it's
popping this bug we actually played and
expressed 25 or 30 dollars just to get
to the front because the line is insane
but it better be worth it because all I
know is that if I spend $80 in MMA I'm
beating everything that's expensive but
rice [ __ ] potatoes look more [ __ ]
crab legs and I'm taking this without a
[ __ ] business the mandatory to have a
kpop hairstyle [ __ ] you
Nishan good afternoon dance yo working
hard
tears and shame only thing that's going
to be letting up a when I'm done all day
so we're giving a breakfast the American
on the first plate we got eggs benedict
mashed potatoes mac and cheese brisket
prime rib some bacon and some scrambled
eggs is literally dinner and breakfast
mix together
I am not counting my macros I don't give
a [ __ ] about what I'm doing here all I
know is I want to make these people hate
me before I leave
that was for any [ __ ] bucks at this
place dude you know we put in place out
of business
Julia's ready doing I'm ready
[ __ ] CIC over your partner crime this
on your itinerary um just get whatever I
see that is I think and ended up dessert
bar what should we do for round two is
the question so right now we bought the
seafood it up real quick on the second
round we got ourselves some lobster
bricks some king crab legs a coconut
ceviche some beurre blanc clams and
that's really about it I'm gonna keep it
light
just to put it in perspective I'm a
[ __ ] novice at this good a little did
I know I have professional buffet can
you tell them what you just did right
now I just thought of this idea so you
know they have a juicer those you socks
you will sink so I really like that
sauce I like the me be marinated it so I
decided to get a bowl of sauce and just
put my meat and put it in this bowl so
marinate nicely and I have all that
I'm a novice I had no idea you could do
that Joo is basically it's like the pan
juicer in the drippings how'd you make
it out of front for whatever buy beef
product that you're making and they use
that as a as a moisture or a dipping
sauce I guess they can get your beat
back into it and she decided to get a
big bowl of it have it soaked in there
gangster novice what you doing video
about her you always got to come and get
the king crab legs all this delicious
like me I will never bite by myself
because I'm [ __ ] cheap as [ __ ]
so instead I come here to get my film I
leave when you go up and you eat almost
like a heavy like greasy food you got it
like even it out with a little soda
I'm not saying soda is healthy for you
but what I am saying is it got bubbles
in it and a half and Festus your bubbles
and makes you burp you see that little
extra space and you're like oh [ __ ]
I guess I'm not as cool as I thought
remember the point of coming to buffet
is to make sure that you hate yourself
back I'm getting there already you know
what time it is then sometime next over
here we have hot and sour soup or as my
people call it stinky person before we
start I know this is a buffet but I'm
very very particular about 30 plates
you know you still got to make it
presentable even if it's out of a faith
we want to look nice one of the benefits
are going to a buffet you can travel
around the [ __ ] world if you
wanted to just because you're going to
eat some Chinese food doesn't mean you
can't visit Italy because over here we
have our parka
we have su mine then I said ha poopy in
the magic card it'll be the mother of
yours
this is a hog out or also known as
shrimp dumpling shrimp dumpling comes
from the province of China where they
don't care about shrimp so they put in
the company if you don't like other
people blank without friends is like a
company with a no meat inside sashimi
with my fingers
I think my biggest kill that I found out
it in Vegas is that I like to talk a lot
of [ __ ]
but I can't do a lot of [ __ ] cool for
example and also this eating finance
which kind of sucks because I'm not the
fattest person at this table but
everybody can eat more than me that's
[ __ ] [ __ ]
so what the [ __ ] is that about how the
[ __ ] about to be fatter than everybody
but I still can't eat as much tip unfair
I love you Jesus and God but jeez come
on making a break now for our final hour
finale I tapped out a little earlier
than everybody else but I wanted to show
you guys a little bit of dessert they
have to offer here for me quintessential
best dessert ever is ice cream of any
kind of store so we got pistachio and
coconut I thought it would be very
complimentary with each other next up we
have this black sesame and green tea
cake we also have
chocolate fudge pudding of some sort in
a chocolate edible cup peppermint bark
as well pineapple and then some creme
brulee pineapple just because my help I
heard it helps with digestion I'm not
sure if that's true or not on the hook
this is the baseline Bobo drink in
history I'd all right
it's got like coconut sorbet on top is
for you pretty much create a dollars for
it
that Alright a dollar but you'll try
this orange dear ice cream yeah I know
you want me to try it but this sounds
like an ass [ __ ] flavor left one this
one yep
that is not pleasant at all
oh wow what the [ __ ]
like that
so if you were to bet money right now
we're betting money he we we lost by two
points they lost by 20 who do you have
your money on for the next one
it doesn't matter two separate games do
not educate whose team are you right now
in life
so we just got done finishing he get the
buffet and then obviously making fun of
Geo because that is a what we normally
do around here but it was delicious
it was cool I should tap that a lot
earlier than I thought I was going to
tap out because Julia and Brendan eat a
lot more than me but they're a lot more
thin in movies which doesn't really
[ __ ] make sense
so god is funny like that that's cool
whatever I don't think I really a
dollars worth of food but it's delicious
if you guys come the biggest you got to
make sure that you do end up effect
because if you don't I don't know you're
not really getting the big experience
plus you're going to throw up do things
that you're going to regret and then
also try a lot of drugs I didn't either
though